we're offering an iPad programming
course the spring in the HCI and we're
very excited about it because it's being
co taught by a top industry developer of
ipad apps and a professor whose research
focuses on how people interact with
information and new ways for people to
interact with information so I'm really
excited about this course because it
combines cutting-edge development on the
iPad platform with research and tools
from human computer interaction so the
idea is that we can help students with
not just understanding how to program
but this is deciding what they can
program so how can they take information
and turn it into knowledge and insight
to do that through ipad maps we really
hope to bridge HCI theory with software
engineering practice and introduce
students to wide variety of techniques
for data visualization and then show
them how to put those techniques into
practice and make great apps that that
use them right now we have students from
all over the school who are involved and
interested so from computer science to
human computer interaction to design to
electrical engineering and I think this
is just a really popular area we're
interacting with information in a
completely different way now we can kind
of hold it in our hands and sit back
with it we can access it from anywhere
and I think it's making students really
interested in that you know in the
classroom we can deal with maybe 30
students maybe 60 students but by
putting it on iTunes U I think it's this
great opportunity for many many more
people to access and learn from that
well we don't assume any previous
experience developing for iOS so we're
going to be teaching introductory topics
about
how to build apps how to make use of the
tools and frameworks that make up the
iOS sdk we're going to be focusing on on
a top-down software engineering approach
that's kind of user-centered using some
of the new newest features of iOS 5 such
as storyboarding for rapid prototyping
your UI and then of course professor
Couture will be teaching topics in
usability theory and data visualization
that we hope to interleave with the
software engineering topics that teach
how to put those into practice so coming
out of the course we're hoping for
students to have the intellectual
background as well as the tools to build
the next generation of iPad applications
developing new ways for them to for
people around the world to interact with
information and make sense of it the
human-computer interaction Institute or
the HCI I is really the ideal place in
the world for this class to be located
we have students here at Carnegie Mellon
who are top programmers and who are
interested not just in programming for
its own sake but programming to improve
people's lives and in ways that are the
most usable the most enjoyable the most
successful for the people who use them
you